so uh this Pete right now this is a wake
Pete that's right I am conscious but
there is a whole other Pete and I call
him middle of the night Pete and that
Pete thinks of some really weird stuff
in the middle of the night right around
4:00 I am but luckily I finally found a
home for middle of the night Pete's
weird revelations in a segment we like
to call 4:00 a.m. thoughts this is kind
of lonely
way better if they're called the x-men
doesn't that mean that there's also ex
women how can we take their plea for
equality between mutants and humans
seriously if they don't even have
quality amongst themselves it's weird
how in romantic comedies the audience in
the theater is filled with people who
actually have sex watching actors
pretend to have sex and that's better
than just staying home and having sex
how do we know that cause his name was
really jaws maybe his name was Larry
wily coyote he's probably wily coyote
was probably single-handedly keeping
that Advil
pride again sweetie wily coyote was
probably single-handedly keeping that
anvil supplier in business
you want another anvil what'd you do
with the last hand of it trying to
squash it what now worth it you know one
thing they never showed on Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles was the shredder
probably walked in on them masturbating
all the time I mean they were teenagers
and ninjas ninjas masturbate alone
read a book why are a lien 'he's always
probing things they can travel
intergalactically but they still want to
look up our butts maybe they've just
seen so many black holes wait for it now
they want to see some brown one